ted is standing by with your forecast i
bet you've had a night
at some point ted and he'll show up
there wait wait there he is
you've had a hofbrau house night at some
point oh yes it's a fun place
yeah and you got to do it at least once
and it gets a little foggy later on on
half a house night
fun place to go for sure live look
outside clear skies and i like using
this tower cam again
because we talk about the winds all
right and we have a light breeze out
there right now but this
camera this tower cam and those palm
trees are going to be blowing tomorrow
for sure 84 degrees are high here you go
brian i wanted to answer your question
there
80 84 high for the day today 64 for the
overnight low
77 is where we should be so again still
riding above average for this time of
the year
record 91 that was set way back in 1990.
now onto some of our neighborhoods here
we start off
up there in the northwest part of the
valley centennial hills at 85
sky canyon same for you spring valley 83
86 north or 85 for north las vegas and
downtown 86 for whitney ranch in green
valley
87 currently for henderson mountain zed
you're at 70 right now actually that
should be actually in the 80s i think
that might be 80 degrees
for mountains edge and southern
highlands we'll double check on that for
you but otherwise still nice and
warm for you in the southwest part of
the valley they're in for insparata and
also rhodes ranch 82 for pro right now
91
for loughlin still 93 warmer out there
in death valley we're getting there
right with that warmth
southwest radar we had those clouds this
morning notice the west to east
uh west to east movement here that's
where those clouds were this morning now
they moved off towards the east in the
four corners region unfortunately did
not bring us any precip and nor do we
expect any with this latest system
what it will do though as it dives down
in the southern great basin
is bring us some uh stronger winds that
we're going to see tomorrow now
your wind forecast doesn't show up being
an issue tomorrow morning
but we get to midday it gets a little
breezy and then there's the afternoon
that's when we really get those winds to
ramp up and tomorrow
night is what we're looking at for eight
news down at 11 where we'll see those
strongest wind gusts we think tomorrow
in the evening
as they could peak up to 45 in many
spots for our wind gusts
wednesday still some leftover breezes
but the big wind day again is going to
be
on tuesday wednesday still some breezy
winds thursday some light breezes as
well
next week we'll see those winds return
again on sunday meanwhile your forecast
overnight 62 degrees look for increasing
clouds but your winds still stay light
85 for tomorrow windy and dusty with the
strongest winds in the evening so still
nice and warm tomorrow
it's the next day we're going to see
that cool down with wednesday being 77
degrees
and thursday only 75 for a high that
puts us right near average
your weekend looking good another warm
one back in those
80s denise all right ted